whoa I mean they're held to account for
their mistakes like anybody else people
lose trust in them it hurts the market
dynamic certainly but more than that it
just hurts the underline or it's the
democracy I mean we do pay a price for
being wrong it it damages our
credibility and as a result of damages
the exchange of ideas in the democracy
it's very important to have a bond of
trust between the press and and and the
public and that's why I get very
frustrated with this era of politicians
who find the easiest response to so many
things is to say that media is terrible
the media is off when we can't trust
them either by us their bias left their
bias right everyone wants to talk to me
because the easiest thing to do because
people buy it now because people are
willing to play the media and I think
it's very irresponsible because it might
be the easiest way to wriggle yourself
out of a question but over time it does
a great disservice to the democracy and
you know I always say to politicians
when this comes up you know you don't
want to be you know you don't want me to
judge you by by the worst politician in
your business you know you don't want me
to judge you by the idea of a Washington
politician well you know all I ask is
the same courtesy from you and they they
generally get that